[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de
présidentielle à 360 voici les titres la
campagne sans relâche de marine le pen
sur le terrain après l' usine oil pour
le damien hier la candidate fn était ce
matin au chevet des pêcheurs au
grau-du-roi dans le gard avant un grand
meeting ce soir à nice nous serons en
direct dans un instant et pendant ce
temps emmanuel macron cherche lui aussi
à faire campagne dans les territoires
oubliés il était cet après midi à
sarcelles en seine-saint-denis pour
faire taire les critiques d'une campagne
tardive
reportage à suivre la sociologie
électorale du premier tour fait
apparaître une france facts fracture est
coupée en deux voire en quatre sets
france de la fracture sociale théorisée
par emmanuel todd et reprise en 95 par
jacques chirac et à laquelle les
politiques successives n'ont jamais
vraiment apporté de réponse sera t-elle
la clé du second tour on posera la
question à mes invités
et je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
réagir à cette émission sur twitter avec
le hashtag présidentielle à 360 pour
m'accompagner cet après midi jusqu'à
18h30 19h30 quand un calme et en direct
du palais nikaïa de nice le multiplex
est tout de suite
tous les ayants titre marine le pen
enchaîne les déplacements après la
visite surprise des ouvriers grévistes
damien la candidate frontiste était dès
potron minet en mer avec les pêcheurs du
grau du roi pour un discours axé sur le
protectionnisme et l'europe avant un
meeting à naissains flora sauvages les
sondages la donnent toujours battu au
second tour de la présidentielle mais
marine le pen ne lâche rien devant les
caméras dès potron minet elle part en
mer avec les pêcheurs de grau du roi
dans le gard et la candidate tacle
emmanuel macron tient beaucoup moins un
concurrent de va le perdre de paix
minutes et pourtant les gares les
métiers qui sont extrêmement pénible et
je crois que le métier de marin-pêcheur
fait partie de ces métiers sont très
pénibles
mérite que le 2
fruit du travail qu'on en tire soit à la
hauteur de l'effort que vont ces
travailleurs occuper le terrain
médiatique tout en allant à la rencontre
des français
une stratégie qui semble payer puisque
l'écart se resserre entre les deux
concurrents
emmanuel macron perd quatre points dans
un sondage doxa diffusé aujourd'hui
mais c'est le travail le trader
ses amis des grandes orgues des grandes
puissances financières on voit bien
d'ailleurs là le plus grand mal à parler
à la france qui travaille et la bataille
médiatique se fait aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux
le fondateur dans marche s'est empressé
de commenter la sortie en mer de marine
le pen ce matin madame le pen se promène
à la pêche
bonne promenade la sortie de l'europe
qu'elle propose c'est la fin de la pêche
française
pensez-y ce soir à nice marine le pen
réuni ses soutiens autour d'elle pour
son premier meeting de l'entré deux
tours l'objectif convaincre les
électeurs de droite alors même que le
maire de la ville christian estrosi
appelle à faire barrage au front
national en votant pour emmanuel macron
le 7 mai et justement on va retrouver
notre envoyé spécial sur place quand un
calme et bon soir quand un marine le pen
a doit s'exprimer d'ici quelques minutes
maintenant
ça a été rappelé par flora sauvage dans
cette ville est bien ou christian
estrosi a rappelé bien qu'il fallait
faire barrage au front national clermont
va t elle s'adapter à cette situation et
bien un premier grand meeting de
l'entre-deux tours pendant une le pen
ici à nice et les militants arrivent
tout juste un au palais nikaïa avec tout
autour plusieurs compagnies de crs des
barrières de sécurité et un important
service d'ordre c'est le peut accueillir
à peu près 9500 personnes d'après les
organisateurs
un meeting qui doit commencer à 20
heures delphine avec uniquement une
seule prise de parole celle de la
candidate marine le pen une candidate
qui a préparé son arrivée ici avec une
inteview à nice matin une interview
publiée aujourd'hui dans laquelle est
bien elle insiste sur les valeurs de
droite puisqu'elle parle de maîtrise des
frontières nationales de soutien aux tpe
et aux pme
on est déjà loin du discours très social
qui étaient tenus aux ouvriers en début
de semaine à rungis ou how will poole
car ici le fn le sait il y a à
disposition un important vivier
d'électeurs les républicains qui sont
déboussolés depuis la défaite de
françois fillon au premier tour et c'est
tout l'enjeu ce soir c'est de convaincre
ses électeurs de françois fillon
d'autant qu'ici les ténors de la droite
se disputent ils ne sont pas d'accord
christian estrosi patron de la région
paca qui a appelé dès dimanche soir à
voter pour emmanuel macron quand tu es
bien eric ciotti le président
du département lui était beaucoup plus
évasif sur la question insistant
beaucoup plus sur les législatives
voyez à delphine des tensions au sein de
la famille des républicains marine le
pen entend bien profiter ce soir à nice
merci beaucoup et quand on vous
retrouvera tout au long de cette édition
et puis à noter que le parlement
européen évalue désormais à près de 5
millions d'euros son préjudice ce
potentiel pour les salaires qui ont été
versés frauduleusement à des assistants
d'eurodéputés eiffel entre 2012 et 2017
et dans ce duel à distance entre les
deux finalistes de cette présidentielle
emmanuel macron a choisi d'occuper le
terrain de la banlieue avec un
déplacement dans ces territoires oubliés
dont le vote pourrait jouer un rôle clé
dimanche 7 mai cessé de sexo décèle fi
des demandes d'autographes ou qui détour
à sarcelles l'accueil est plus
chaleureux qu'à amir hier dans la
bataille de l'image
emmanuel macron est désormais offensif
en rendant visite à une association
d'insertion par le sport
le candidat dans marche sans pause sur
le terrain et reprend la main sur la
campagne pour ne plus se laisser
distancer dans la compétition par marine
le pen
la france ça n'est pas ce visage haineux
et rétrécit que par madame le pen je ne
la laisserai pas porter ce visage de la
france je ne la laisserai pas banaliser
ce qu'est le parti du front national qui
est à partie et nos folles est là mais à
la tête de ce parti quelqu'un qui a eu
des positions extraordinairement grave
le candidat dans marche est également
venu chercher chez eux
les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon à
sarcelles le candidat de la france
insoumise afic 30% des voix au premier
tour des élections présidentielles
éteindra nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
bonsoir tam avec vous on va passer au
crible les propos à la fois des manuels
macro et aussi de marine le pen on
commence avec emmanuel macron le
candidat en marche hier qui en meeting à
rask qui a alerté sur les dangers du
protectionnisme
on écoute tout de suite d'airs le projet
de madame le pen c'est quoi
sortir de l'euro ça veut dire que votre
épargne demain elle perdra au moins 30 %
de ce qu'elle vaut ça veut dire que vos
salaires diminueront en vrai ils seront
dans une autre monnaie mais ce que vous
consommez via en majorité de l'étranger
et donc cette monnaie ne changera pas le
coût de tout ce que nous importons
augmentera et donc nous nous appauvrir
on a pas celles et ceux qui vivent dans
des châteaux les classes moyennes les
classes populaires elles s'appauvriront
chaque jour qu'elle consomme sortir de
l'europe
mais qu'est ce que cela veut dire le
protectionnisme c'est la guerre tam est
ce que notre épargne la perdre 30% si on
quitte l'union européenne mais écoutez
si la france revenait au franc de
nombreux économistes pensent que la zone
euro voire l'union européenne
imploserait de façon non voulues par les
autres membres
donc de façon non coordonnées que chacun
retournerait à sa monnaie d'avant que ça
serait donc un chaos politique et
économique est bien résultats dans ce
scénario là en tout cas est bien la
perte de valeur de l'épargné des
français ne serait que le moindre mal
admettons qu on en arrive pas la moins
bien effectivement un plus un groupe de
réflexion également planché sur des
scénarios où il n'ya pas l'implosion de
l'union européenne
par exemple si on parle de l'institut
montaigne il prévoit une dévaluation du
franc de 15%
l'envolée des taux d'intérêt la très
forte augmentation de la dette publique
est finalement un recul du pib de 2,3 à
3 2 % la première année
et puis une chute de 4 à 13 % sur le
long terme
mais voilà ce n'est qu'un scénario parmi
d'autres donc la perte en tout cas de
valeur de l'epagne évoqué par emmanuel
macron aurait certainement lieu mais
elle est très difficilement chiffrables
ans dans la même si radan a entendu
emmanuel macron s'écrie le
protectionnisme c'est la guerre est ce
qu'on peut dire ça bien écouter le
protectionnisme c'est tout de même un
outil qui fait partie de la gamme
normale des outils d'un état un
instrument qui existe partout dans le
monde et qui ne signifie donc pas
aujourd'hui nécessairement la guerre
s'il est utilisé dans un cadre
collaboratif si les pays continuent tout
de même d'échanger les uns avec les
autres et ailleurs
emmanuel macron n'est pas défavorable
certaines mesures de protectionnisme
mais au niveau européen c'est donc faux
nom on peut dire que c'est un slogan
c'est un raccourci en fait dans son
argumentation d'ailleurs on l'a entendu
en entier ce que dit emmanuel macron
c'est le protectionnisme 2 marine le pen
c'est la guerre est là d'ailleurs il
convoque plusieurs mémoires rendant ses
tirades tout au long du discours d'arras
d'abord celle de la deuxième guerre
mondiale puisque le programme du front
national on l'a déjà dit c'est donc le
retour au franc potentiellement la
destruction l'union européenne une union
d'abord créé pour mettre fin aux guerres
qui ont ensanglanté l europe tout au
long du xxème siècle et d'ailleurs
certains historiens estiment que le
retour en france ça serait le retour de
la guerre des monnaies les dévaluations
compétitives
effectivement la perte de pouvoir
d'achat pour les plus modestes est le
terreau de ce qui a ensuite entraîné la
montée dans les années 30 des extrêmes
ensuite emmanuel macron convoque une
autre mémoire celle de la première
guerre mondiale serve de la bataille de
la somme en est d'ailleurs à arras et à
la fin de son discours les manières
macro parle des somnambules du 21e
siècle c'est une référence au livre de
l'historien christopher clarke sur les
causes de la grande guerre et les
somnambules et bien ce sont ces hommes
politiques qui ont des oeillères qu'ils
ne se rendent pas compte des cas ce que
leurs calculs mesquins peuvent avoir des
répercussions incalculables à savoir la
première guerre mondiale
et puis enfin dans cette phrase il
convoque la mémoire de françois
mitterrand le nationalisme c'est la
guerre disait françois mitterrand
l'ancien président de la république au
parlement européen pour dire la
nécessité de l'europe
en résumé tom et bien emmanuel macron a
raison lorsqu'il dit que les épargnants
pas tirer énormément de la sortie de la
france de l'union européenne même s'il
est impossible de donner un chiffrage
précis
par ailleurs le candidat dans marche
fait le lien entre protectionnisme et
guerre un slogan un peu rapide mais qui
convoque l'histoire pour justifier la
défense de l'union européenne
merci beaucoup tam on retrouve d'ici une
heure on parlera cette fois du programme
de marine le pen est dans cette campagne
pour l'élection présidentielle pour ce
second tour un mouvement est en train se
mettre en place celui du ni ni
ni le pen ni macron il touche les primo
votants les lycéens mais aussi les
étudiants qui ont d'ailleurs manifesté à
paris aujourd'hui
nelson getten ni marine ni macron ils
étaient près d'un millier de lycéens à
chanter ce slogan ce matin dans les rues
de paris entre république et nation
l'objectif protester contre les
résultats du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle à laquelle ils n'ont pas
pu prendre part
je suis mineur et j'ai pas eu d' j'ai
pas du tout mon mot à dire alors que je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec ce qui se
passe donc en fait aulas aujourd'hui je
suis dans la rue pour pour essayer faire
entendre ma voix à quoi je pense que
c'est à peu près tout y est dans ce cas
là tout le monde
pas vraiment en arrivant à bastille un
groupe de casseurs est sorti du cortège
avant de renverser des poubelles et
vandalisé des affiches publicitaires
les forces de police ont rapidement
répliqué avec du gaz lacrymogène
face à cette violence les réactions des
lycéens divergent
j'avais pas envie que ça tourne comme ça
ce que ça nous donne un côté un peu
abruti en quelque sorte et
c'est pas l'image qu'on veut renvoyer je
me demande ce qui est mieux entre une
manifestation pacifique est une
manifestation où il ya des débordements
parce que les deux ont un effet sur
l'opinion publique d'un côté si cette
manifestation bastié qu'on peut avoir
une bonne image des manifestants de
l'autre une manifestation violente ça
peut faire ça on en parle beaucoup plus
et on l'entend dans ton beaucoup plus
parler tôt ce matin le lycée voltaire et
trois autres établissements parisiens
avaient été totalement bloquée par les
élèves
visiblement il avait un message pour un
candidat
déjà éliminés au premier tour quelle
mobilisation des syndicats le 1er mai le
traditionnel défilé des principales
centrales pour la fête du travail qui
s'était transformé en 2002 en une
immense marée humaine contre le fn
divise aujourd'hui les organisations
syndicales les explications des louise
grégoire pas de mot d'ordre commun pour
ce traditionnel 1er mai les deux grands
syndicats la cgt et la cfdt n'ont pas
trouvé de compromis sur le message de la
mobilisation la cfdt organise une
manifestation contre le front national
et appelle in fine et à voter pour
emmanuel macron c'est choquant même que
pour le 1er mai on soit pas capable de
se rassembler parce que le 1er mai
traditionnellement il ya toujours du
monde dans la rue donc c'était vraiment
l'opportunité de dire tous ensemble le
front national ne passera pas par nous
la cgt souhaite elle a un mot d'ordre
plus large et moins ciblée sur l'extrême
droite défiler dans la rue aujourd'hui
en disant simplement il faut faire
barrage au fn sans s'attaquer aux causes
sans revendications sociales sans dire
le programme de macron c'est le
programme de hollande aggravé et qu'il
va continuer d'accroître le vote fn
c'est ne faire qu'une moitié du travail
et nous ne sommes pas là pour ça
le syndicat de philippe martinez se
range aux côtés de force ouvrière qui
traditionnellement ne donne aucune
consigne de vote
manifestera le 1er mai avec d'autres
organisations le cgt la fsu solidaires
les étudiants les lycéens avec une
banderole qui sera contre les reculs
sociaux terreau de l'extrême droite et
vous informons que vous tenez pas de ce
qu'on nous donne jamais de consigne de
vote considérons que c'est pas de la
responsabilité du syndicat en 2002 les
organiser
si on syndicales à l'exception de force
ouvrière avaient manifesté contre
l'extrême droite
quinze ans après l'image ne sera donc
pas au rendez vous
la fracture sociale fait elle son retour
dans la campagne présidentielle c'est un
thème qui avait permis à jacques chirac
d'être élu en 1995
hier emmanuel macron arrêt employer
cette expression lors de son meeting
arras mais la candidate qui jusque là
peut-être le mieux intégré
l'enjeu des inégalités territoriales
c'est marine le pen alors avant d'en
parler avec mes invités on voit tout de
suite ce sujet de mounir sont si la
présence de marine le pen et d'emmanuel
macron au second tour traduit-elle
l'existence de de france à la vue des
résultats par département un clivage
géographique net apparaît mais ce
raccourci d'un pays coupé en deux et
fréquemment empruntée depuis les 20
dernières années en 1995 jacques chirac
fait décoller sa campagne en
popularisant le thème de la fracture
sociale
la formule fait mouche à l'époque le
futur président point que le fossé qui
se creuse entre les citoyens les mieux
intégrés sur le plan social et
économique et les autres tenues à
l'écart de l'emploi ce thème de campagne
sera suivie de peu d'effets durant son
mandat
dix ans après ce constat cette fracture
se traduit notamment par la crise des
banlieues qui vient confirmer isolement
d'une partie de la population
une fois à l'elysée nicolas sarkozy
souhaite s'emparer de la question
on va mettre en place un dans les quinze
jours qui viennent un plan qui est un
plan comme les autres s'agit pas de
s'occuper des immeubles
ce cube s'agit de s'occuper des
personnes finalement ce plan marshall
sera bien ciblée sur la rénovation
urbaine et ne répondra pas totalement
besoin de ses quartiers au fil des ans
la frontière de la fracture sociale se
déplace aujourd'hui c'est la france
périphérique qui est au coeur des débats
du territoire éloigné de grandes
métropoles où les difficultés
économiques et sociales se concentre une
thèse que françois hollande a réfuté
tout au long de son quinquennat
y'a pas de quartiers perdus dans la
république il ya une france périphérique
à côté d'une france des villes une
france tranquille non il y à la france
dans laquelle l'égalité doit être
assurée fracture sociale crise des
banlieues france périphérique
ces phénomènes ont tous la même source
le chômage de masse qui touche le pays
depuis plus de 30 ans et en ouvrons le
débat avec mes invités ce soir sur ce
plateau frédéric gilli bonsoir
économiste enseignant à sciences po
merci d'être avec nous j'accueille
également daniel béart bonsoir vous êtes
géographe professeur à l'école
d'urbanisme de paris
merci d'être avec nous et pour nous
accompagner pendant ce débat stéphane la
zone stick vous êtes directeur du
département opinion 'acheter' ipsos
merci à tous les trois premières
questions pour vous frédéric elle julie
c'est vrai qu'on a vu réapparaître ce
thème de fracture territoriale de cette
france coupée en deux est ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est suffisant pour
expliquer la poussée du vote front
national en france
non c'est à dire que vous avez
en entrant en lançant le sujet on sait
dans la même phrase retour de la
fracture sociale et fracture
territoriale le pays il est multi
fracturée mais il est tellement multi
fracture et qu'en fait on peut plus
opposer un pays à un autre ça a pas
véritablement de sens c'est à dire que
il ya effectivement des difficultés
sociales intenses
elles sont certaines sont concentrés
dans les autres dans des endroits bien
identifiés dans les banlieues dans
certains territoires ruraux mais aussi
en plein coeur des de certaines villes
donc la dimension territoriale de cette
fracture sociale elle n'est pas évidente
de la même manière il y a un sentiment
de crise démocratique de représentation
pour beaucoup d'habitants des
territoires non métropolitains mais ça
recouvre pas exactement la même
géographique et celle de la crise
sociale et donc quand on regarde le
résultat du premier tour par exemple qui
a fait la une du monde de lundi matin
avec une france face à face c'est une
lecture extrêmement simplifié qui est
qui en fait il résulte du fait qu'on a
regardé les cas les communes dans
lesquelles marine le pen arrivait en
tête
beaucoup de communes rurales ça fait une
grande place et on a conclu que dans ces
communes dans lesquelles marine le pen
arrivait en tête
en moyenne elle ne fait pas plus de 30%
dans les territoires périurbains dans
l'écriture tout un dans les territoires
ruraux ni quoi que ce soit 30% c'est
énorme c'est important c'est grave mais
c'est parce 50 ou 60% de la population
est donc partout ailleurs on a dans
toute la france manuel macro ont fait
pas moins de 1% dans les territoires
ruraux
il fait pas moins de 1 % dans les zones
périurbaines donc en fait la question
qui se pose
elle est peut-être moins de d'opposer
les gens que de se demander comment est
ce que on rigole on résout ensemble
villes et territoires ruraux personnes
insérées et personnes en difficulté
sociale
comment est-ce qu'on résout ce défi de
créer de la richesse nous ensemble mais
elle a distribué mais elle a partagé
mais ça c'est un autre problème
pollution sur le constat de la fracture
on voit que la biographie du vote fn
daniel baer est extrêmement complexe est
ce qu elle comment on peut expliquer
alors ce vote protestataire si ce n'est
pas cette source de cette france
périphérique
oui bah déjà en phase pour rebondir sur
ce que j'ai à dire fazeli enfin moi ce
qui m'a frappé dans votre premier
reportage là c'est qu'il ya deux façons
de dire la fracture on dit fracture
territoriale met la première carte que
vous me montrez c'est une fracture
géographique entre eux en gros l'est et
l'ouest de la france
et puis ensuite dans le propos du
journaliste et puis dans ce qu'on entend
aujourd'hui il ya plutôt une fracture
territoriale en strates les grandes
villes contre le rural contre les villes
moyennes contre ce qu'on appelle la
france préfère c'est pas du tout la même
chose
or autant c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même
aujourd'hui tendanciellement du point de
vue des inégalités sociales et
économiques plutôt une fracture entre la
france delhaize la vieille france
industrielle etc et la france de l'ouest
autant la différence entre les strates
elle prête à une lecture très politique
qui oppose de deux fractions de la
société française
les élites contre le peuple les élites
métropolitaine contre le peuple rural et
je crois que celle là elle est
complètement fausse elle est
complètement fausse et je vais pas
reprendre ce que vient de dire frédéric
c'est à dire qu'en effet il ya
aujourd'hui autant de gens qui votent
paris dans les métropoles dia il ya
trois métropoles 3102 métropole clients
qui ont voté qui me classer en tête
mélenchon est étroit et trois métropoles
de nature complètement différente
marseille toulouse et lille il ya plus
de la moitié des villes moyennes qui ont
voté qui ont mis en tête le pen est ce
que c'est moi qui ont mis un terme à
cran donc voilà on ne peut pas opposer
derrière la fracture géographique on en
fait une fracture sociétale et je pense
que c'est faux et du coup enfin moi je
pense que ce qui explique en partie ce
vote
plutôt protestataires dans les
territoires ruraux ville moyenne etc
c'est c'est pas la mondialisation et ont
dit les victimes de la mondialisation
moi je je distinguerai de la
mondialisation de la globalisation la
globalisation c'est ce qu'on vit tous
les jours s'est passé quelque chose qui
nous vient de l'extérieur et qu'on subit
la globalisation c'est ce qu'on fait
tous les tous quand on passe d'un mode
de vie qui était le mode de vie locale
en bassin de vie etc en plus tôt on
habite en un endroit l'an de consommer
un ailleurs etc et donc on globalise
notre pratique du territoire et du coup
il me semble que dans les territoires de
la france dit périphériques les derniers
territoires ruraux dans les territoires
des villes moyennes
mais c'est là qu'il ya le plus grand
écart entre le mythe qu'on a mais la
france des terroirs la france des pays
enfin cette france des bassins de vie
etc
et puis la réalité que les uns et les
autres on fabrique ou en fait on vit
plus en bassin où vit en archipel et
donc du coup c'est ce décalage est une
simple qui fait une des facteurs
explicatifs du vote front national c'est
qu'il ya une forme de souffrance et
c'est un politiste bruno latour qui
dégaine souffrance spatiale des français
moi je pense que c'est pas complètement
faux la souffrance spatiale c'est c'est
le fait qu on nous reconnaît plus les
territoires dans lesquels on vit
stéphane c'est qu'est ce que on a quand
même le sentiment si que marine le pen
s'est appuyé justement pour préparer
cette élection présidentielle sur ces
deux travaux d'une france oublié ce sont
des territoires qu'elle a
particulièrement ciblé ce qu'on peut
quand même bien en tenir compte pour
expliquer les motivations des électeurs
frontistes
elle a labouré toutes ces terres et et
on s'adressant à des catégories sociales
très typé bien sûr mais est là et c'est
un salut c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
le front national
et c'est aussi le signe que c'est un
parti qui s'installent définitivement
alors ça fait 20 ou 30 ans qu'on dit que
le front national s'installe bien sûr
mais élection après élection type de
scrutin après scrutin
on se rend compte que ce n'est plus un
parti de bastions ya encore quelques
années avant les européennes de 2014 et
les élections régionales et
départementales de 2015 on roule front
national était fort très fort dans
certaines zones le pourtour
méditerranéen l'est de la france est pas
nouveau ça ne date pas de cette année
en revanche maintenant quand on regarde
le front national de marine le pen est à
l'éventail dans 17 min commune alors
évidemment ce sont souvent des petites
communes mais c'est considérable
on a bien constaté en 2015 il n'y a plus
de terre de mission pour le front
national
là où il est et faible extrêmement
femmes si ce n'est insignifiant je pense
notamment à l'ouest de la france à tout
l'arc atlantique un désordre la vallée
de la garonne et on est le cas cette
année évidemment avec des scores fleuves
dans certains petits villages ou dans
des petites villes
mais je pense notamment la bretagne
encore quelques années dans les villages
bretons dans des petites villes
bretonnes
le front national faisait 2 3 4 5 %
aujourd'hui ils offraient de 10 à 20 et
ça vaut pour les petits pour les petits
villages
ça va aussi pour les communes de taille
intermédiaire donc ce n'est plus un
parti de patience pour axe parler de
très bonnes nouvelles pour le front
national parce que pour un parti pour
arriver en tête à certaines élections
intermédiaires comme pour être qualifié
pour le second tour on ne peut pas se
contenter d'avoir des points de force
dans certaines catégories de français
que ce soit des catégories sociales ou
que ce soit des zones territoriales il
faut être bon partout
emmanuel macron il est fort partout
marine le pen aujourd'hui à quelques
rares exceptions près comme les centres
villes des villes riches on va dire pour
faire ça elle est forte partout sur
cette histoire du travail du fn sur le
terrain je pense que cette élection elle
est aussi elle s'inscrit dans ce qu'on a
vu au moment des municipales de 2014
dans ce qu'on a vu au moment des
régionales de 2015 c'est-à-dire
l'effondrement sur soi total des partis
classiques du gouvernement les
républicains quelles que soient leurs
noms successifs où le parti socialiste
et quand on analyse les travaux que
réalise des géographes les sociologues
électoraux qui ont travaillé notamment
sur le travail du duché par les
militants front national en normandie
etc
c'est un parti qui travaille beaucoup et
donc qui travaillent là les gens mais
qui travaille aussi la question de la
crise démocratique dont les autres
partis s'affranchissent très largement
ils considèrent pour beaucoup que la la
le gain électoral il se fait dans un
très joli programme et la désignation
elle se fait entre au sein de l'appareil
je veux pas dire que le front national
fait pas ça mais il se trouve que le
front national fait un travail de
terrain intense et on a vu dans la
campagne de mélenchon notamment qu' une
partie de
scor est sans doute dû au fait que il ya
eu un travail de terrain sur internet
est en réalité dans le terrain physique
que les autres partis ont eu plus de
difficultés à faire pour qu'un de
raisons mais sans doute aussi par un
espèce d'atavisme d'appareils on voyait
dans le reportage daniel verdes de
mounir souci on entendait françois
hollande infection qui réfutait cette
notion de france périphérique et
pourtant je rappeler en cette
interruption ce retour de cette notion
de fracture sociale dans le discours
notamment d' emmanuel macron hier arras
est ce que ça veut dire aussi qu'il ya
quand même des politiques successifs qui
ont échoué à la résorber cette fracture
sociale c'est clair que aujourd'hui on
est on est confrontée à une
multiplication des fractures et qu' on
ne sait pas les résoudre
pourquoi on sait pas les résoudre parce
que on les traite j'irai à la fois
successivement c'est dire que il ya eu
quand on évoquait tout à l'heure jacques
chirac
la fracture territoriale la
superposition fracture sociale fracture
territoriale c'était plutôt au sein des
villes c'était la crise des banlieues
donc on a eu un long moment où on fait
la fracture elle était focalisé à cet
endroit là puis ensuite on a dit la
facture entre la france de métropole et
la france périphérique et donc à chaque
fois on change et on y ait une espèce de
course poursuite à dire où seraient les
victimes de la mondialisation il me
semble que du coup on a une difficulté à
penser à la fois la globalité du
processus de de déstabilisation que
produit ce que j'appelle moi encore une
fois la globalisation plus que la
mondialisation et deuxièmement a inventé
les modes de traitement différencié de
ces situations se faire que par exemple
quand on dit parler la vallée de la
garonne quand on dit voilà les zones de
votre front national sont les vols sont
les zones de forte densité du chômage
oui mais les cesser cette forte densité
du chômage et correspond pas aux mêmes
réalités et aux mêmes explications et
donc au même traitement en termes de
politiques publiques cercle quand vous
prenez en gros le même par exemple la
densité du chômage dans le nord-est de
la france et la densité du chômage dans
le languedoc-roussillon vient en fait
c'est pas du tout le même chômage d'un
côté c'est un chômage dans le nord-est
c'est un chômage
je dirais donc justement c'est des gens
qui peuvent pas en sortir quoi qu'ils
sont
assigné à résidence le chômage du
languedoc-roussillon c'est strictement
l'inversé un chômage d'attractivité sert
les gens viennent parce qu'il ya un
espoir avec le soleil et c' est qu' ils
sont déçus ils sont déçus parce que ils
trouvent du boulot mais il trouve pas du
boulot pour le couple et ils se
retrouvent avec l'un des membres du
couple
et puis deux coups difficultés
d'accession à la propriété etc ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que les modes de
traitement par les politiques publiques
doivent être différenciées et c'est ça
qu'on sait pas faire pire que soit on
unifie c'est ce qu'on a fait récemment
face qu'a fait françois hollande quand
il a dit voilà il ya une seule
géographie prioritaire de la politique
de la ville de la seine saint denis à
guéret soit on fragmente mais on ne sait
pas penser la différenciation des
politiques publiques alors il ya il ya
ça en germe dans le discours de
d'emmanuel macron qui commence à dire il
faut traiter de manière différenciée les
situations il semble que c'est ça le
défi est ce qu'on va être capable de
penser la la la la multiplicité des
situations de fragmentation que produit
la globalisation et de les penser donc
du coup avec des stratégies d'action
publique différenciez vous avez étudié
cette question de la fracture sociale
notamment dans les intentions de vote
dans les ressorts et bien des électeurs
oui bien sûr c'est ce qu'on appelle la
sociologie des électorats interrogés
toute une série de français qui se sont
prononcés dimanche dernier où d'autres
qui se sont abstenus d'ailleurs et on la
croisait tous ces résultats par leur
profil sociodémographique et par leur
profil politique ce qu'on fait à chaque
élection il ya des choses qui sont
persistants par rapport à ce qu'on avait
pu observer mais qui sont encore plus
fortes très nettement marine le pen est
très largement en tête dans l'électorat
ouvrier mais aussi parce qu'on en parle
moins souvent l'électorat employés ont
pas très loin du vote ouvrier oui les
employés sont plus nombreux que les
ouvriers aujourd'hui et c'est au sein de
ces deux catégories
quelques elle enregistre ses meilleurs
scores c'est d'autant plus intéressant
cette année encore qu'il y avait jean
luc mélenchon qui avait une autre offre
neuf de gauche radicale qui en tout cas
si on regarde l'histoire politique
récente était censée répondre aux
aspirations de ces catégories ça n'a pas
été le cas
j'en obtiens des bons scores évidemment
auprès de ces catégories
mais c'était en tout cas bien moindre
que marine le pen
mais là encore évidemment marine le pen
elle est plus faible on va dire chez les
cadres chez les cadres supérieurs mais
ce serait une erreur de dire que marine
le pen est la candidate des pauvres et
que
emmanuel macron du candidat des riches
du système de l'établissement de tout ce
que vous voulez c'est totalement faux
bien sûr que vous près des cadres
supérieurs urbain des centres villes des
grandes villes elle enregistre des
faibles scores mais dans toutes les
autres catégories ce qu'on appelle nous
les catégories intermédiaires les cadres
de maîtrise auprès des fonctionnaires
auprès des salariés en général un
enregistré score tout à fait honorable
pour elle en tout cas et qui sont au
dessus de la de sa moyenne nationale de
22 %
c'est ce que disait tout à l'heure elle
n'a plus de zones de faiblesse à part
quelques petites niches mais qui ne pèse
pas beaucoup il ya ça et pour revenir à
cette idée de fracture sociale ce qui
compte le plus au delà des éléments
objectifs comme sa profession ou son
niveau de revenu c'est le moral des
français ya une vraie peur du
déclassement à mes goûts et tous les
gens qui considèrent que leur profession
est en déclin
tous les gens qui considèrent que les
générations à venir que leurs enfants
vivront moins bien que aujourd'hui tous
les gens qui considèrent qu'ils ont des
fins de mois difficiles ce sont des
questions qu'on a également posé dans ce
type de cas tu es bien massivement entre
reporter leurs intentions de vote sur
marine le pen au premier tour et on fera
le saut livrera au même exercice aux
contours et les chiffres que nous
publierons seront autrement plus
remarquables quelque part parce que là
pour le coup sera pas 30 35 ou 40 % qui
ont voté pour moi une le pen ce sera 50
55 ou 60 % quelle que soit l'issue du
scrutin
mais il ya des catégories où elle sera
très nettement majoritaires et c'est
vrai que c'est difficile on peut par une
réflexion binaire comme ça en disant est
ce que rappelle stéphane zumsteeg marine
le pen candidate des pauvres emmanuel
macron le candidat des riches mais
pourtant y'a quand même ce discours très
ciblé un de la candidate frontiste à
cette france invisible on l'a vu encore
hier avec la séquence auprès des
ouvriers amiens aujourd'hui elle
s'adresse aussi aux pêcheurs elle a
compris dans cette campagne d'entre deux
tours qu'il fallait quand même cibler
ces personnes qui se sentent des classes
et comme le rappelait ce n'est pas james
t c'est à dire que c'est tout le
problème
de ce discours sur la fracture
évidemment qu'il faut la traiter sauf
que aggravé le constat miser sur le
constat qu'il ya une opposition ça fait
le jeu de fêtes de marine le pen
parce qu'en fait pour construire une
société dans laquelle les gens en
confiance les uns dans les autres et il
savait que ce soit pour de la création
de richesse pour de la création
d'associations pour de l'initiative
individuelle ou collective en a besoin
de confiance on a besoin de pas avoir
peur de l'autre si enfin pour faire ça
tout ce qui va nourrir le sentiment que
l'autre est un ennemi que les riches
sont pas bons pour les pauvres et que
les pauvres sont des menaces pour les
riches tout ça ça détruit de la deûle a
détruit l'an commun qu'on a dans ce pays
et de fait il ya des partis politiques
dont le front national qui prospère sur
cette déprime collective donc faire le
diagnostic hâtif que la france est
coupée en deux de fait parler de
l'apartheid social ethnique territoriale
il faisait aussi en quelque sorte ce
constat et c'est pas pareil de dire
qu'il ya des zones qui sont dans une
très grande situation de difficulté
quand il parlait de l'apartheid social
dans les quartiers
quand vous allez dans le quartier
aujourd'hui vous vous rendez cannes bien
compte qu'il ya plein d'endroits en
france dans lesquels il n'y a pas la
même égalité d'accès à l'école n'y a pas
la même égalité d'accès à l'emploi il
n'y a pas la même égalité d'accès à la
culture il n'y a pas donc
c'est pas c'est pas un apartheid on s'en
souvient avait un année en afrique du
sud
mais de fait il ya des quartiers où pour
une raison d' adresse pour une raison
qu'on couleur de peau pour une plein de
raisons différentes diverses et variées
vous n'avez plus accès à la république
est donc le mot de manuel valls était
sans doute très fort mais c'est pas
pareil de dire qu'il ya des zones qui
sont dans une difficulté parce qu'elles
sont traitées différemment que de dire
il ya une france et 50 derrière france
et une métonymie la france c'est 50% de
français qu'on dira c'est à dire vous
avez 30 millions de français qui sont
prêts à se mettre sur la figure avec 30
millions d'autres c'est pas tout à fait
tout à fait la même chose que le dire on
a un problème d'action publique fort
parce que des parties du territoire des
zones rurales ou des quartiers en du sud
des quartiers populaires n'ont pas accès
aux mêmes droits que les autres et après
se pose une deuxième question qui et
comment est ce que on en nous posant les
zones métropolitaines et les zones
rurales
de fait à mon avis on fait en et les
fossoyeurs deux des zones rurales parce
qu'elles ont besoin des zones
métropolitaines
mais on est aussi les fossoyeurs des
zones métropolitaines parce qu'elles
nous ont besoin des zones rurales
beaucoup plus qu'elle ne le pense et
elles ne se rendent même pas compte que
en dix ans en un récent en zone rurale
un discours sur le mode mais arrêtez de
vous plaindre on crée de l'excédent dans
les zones urbaines dont vous bénéficiez
on a un discours de charité bien
ordonnée dont le pays auxquelles le pays
est allergique depuis 1789 enfin là
l'idée que l'on n'est pas à vivre de 2
de son destin ça hérisse le poil de tout
le monde dans ce pays et donc on peut
pas tenir un discours aux territoires
ruraux quand on est une grande métropole
2 sur le mode mais rassurez vous tout va
bien se passer pour vous parce qu'on
crée de l'excédent et on va vous faire
vivre avec les minima sociaux
c'est pas possible c'est pas entendable
politiquement et démocratiquement
d'ailleurs vous avez commencé à ébaucher
quelques pistes justement pour parler à
ces territoires qui peuvent se sentir
relégué tenu à l'écart de la république
qu'elle serait justement comment moi je
crois que globalement enfin notamment
vis-à-vis des territoires ddt où ladite
france périphérique mais toujours des
guillemets moi je pense qu'il ya il ya
un message de conduire une forme de
pédagogie du changement parce que j'ai
encore une fois je pense que ce qui fait
ce qui les déstabilisent c'est le fait
de ne plus retrouver de repères c'est la
fin d'un certain ordre territoriales
qu'est ce qui fait que les villes
moyennes souffre etc
c'est que voilà elle était installée
chef lui d'un bassin de vie et c est que
les gens eux mêmes ont détruit sa ont
détruit sa avec les commerces de
périphérie etc et donc du coup c'est
comment on redonne de la lisibilité aux
territoires dans lesquels chacun vis et
comment on adresse un message de
confiance à ces territoires et puis
deuxièmement ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur la différenciation moi je
pense qu on peut pas traiter par tous
cette question de la même manière et je
peux je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre
de notamment d'or dans ces territoires
ruraux des villes moyennes je reprends
la question de la france de l'est parce
que j'insiste là dessus pour moi la
première fracture c est ouest quoi la
france de l'est on n'a pas eu le courage
dans les politiques publiques de dire
qu'il ya un certain nombre de
territoires aujourd'hui dont les gens
sont partis ou en tout cas une patte
vous partie de la population s'en va et
où du coup la l'espèce de
représentations dominantes qu'un
territoire qui va bien c'est un
territoire qui se développe il ya de la
croissance etc
c'est pas nécessairement vrai partout et
qu'on d'une certaine manière qu'on peut
vivre heureux et moins nombreux j'irai à
charleville mézières ou à bar-le-duc et
donc du coup que que par exemple
l'action publique les services publics
organisent un retrait en bon ordre
c'est le maire de chalon comme on dit
maintenant châlons-en-champagne qui le
dit et qui de ce point de vue là benoist
apparu me semble assez lucide qui dit
voilà moi je dans les dix ans qui
viennent avec la fin de l'année etc
je vais devoir fermer dix écoles et bien
au lieu de le faire contre un effort et
forcé henry en catimini
j'assume et j'ai un plan et je
accompagner le changement voilà et là
dessus il me semble que les politiques
sont mais manque de courage
quoi d une certaine manière on va on
trouve à dire partout la même chose quoi
vous avez droit au développement etc
non il ya aujourd'hui des territoires
qui sont des territoires qui sont un peu
en situation de gel etc et qui peut-être
redéveloppement dans 20 ans
quand on dit quand on t'envoie le massif
central le site central perdre et de la
population depuis dix ans il en gagne
bon il faut assumer oc cycle de vie
les territoires et avoir des politiques
publiques un peu pragmatique rapidement
et pour conclure stéphane asustek
justement sur les intentions de vote que
vous vous commencé à sonder pour le
second tour ces questions de cette
france multi fracturé sont très
présentes dans les motivations des
électeurs parmi les principales
motivations des français et d'ailleurs
c'est et ce sera encore plus le cas dans
l'entre-deux-tours qu'avant le premier
tour toutes les problématiques sociales
sont au coeur de la hauteur des attentes
des français
marine le pen on a parlé jean luc
mélenchon on a parlé d'autres candidats
aussi céder il n'y avait pas que deux
évidemment quand on demande aux français
qu est-ce qui comptera le plus au moment
du choix de vote dans dix jours
maintenant c'est la défense du pouvoir
d'achat la réduction des inégalités
sociales qui arrive avant le terrorisme
ou l'insécurité c'est à dire layton qui
indépendamment de ce qui s'est passé sur
les champs se disait il ya quelques
jours c'est à dire les thèmes majeurs
qui ont fait l'actualité ces dernières
années sont relégués en troisième
quatrième cinquième position pouvoir
d'achat réduction des inégalités
sociales et évidemment lutte contre le
chômage bien merci à tous les trois
d'être venu sur ce plateau on continue
l'analyse et le décryptage des enjeux de
ce second tour car il ya ces 20%
d'électeurs de françois fillon qui
d'aujourd'hui sont partagés sur
l'attitude à adopter pour le second tour
si certains ont entendu l'appel à voter
emmanuel macron de l'ancien premier
ministre
d'autres oscille encore entre abstention
et vote frontiste marine le pen elle a
bien compris elle courtise cette partie
de l'électorat de la droite
traditionnelle est catholique
reportage dans la sarthe et dans l'orne
de paris brémaud et géraldine beys voit
l'eau
[Musique]
à l'issue du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle seuls cinq départements
métropolitains ont placé françois fillon
en tête
nous avons décidé de prendre la route
direction l'orne et la sarthe des terres
sioniste afin de recueillir la parole
des électeurs en vue du second tour des
électeurs de droite vous allez le voir
décider écartelé ou encore indécis la
ferté-bernard ville de 9000 habitants au
nord de la sarthe
au premier tour françois fillon est
arrivé largement devant les autres
candidats avec 31% des voix dans un
quartier pavillonnaire en bordure de la
départementale 3 123 nous rencontrons
claude en train de bâches et ses pommes
de terre en prévision du gel annoncé
ancien agriculteur à la retraite depuis
23 ans il a toujours voté à droite par
tradition il y a cinq jours lui et sa
femme yvette avec qui il est marié
depuis 55 ans ils ont choisi françois
fillon le sarthois pour la suite
c'est tout sauf marine le pen elle
appelle son père le mari me causer elle
est un peu
jacuzzi et paris malgré leurs petites
retraites
1400 euros à eux deux et beaucoup
d'interrogations suscité par le candidat
citadins emmanuel macron claude et
yvette ne céderons pas aux sirènes du fn
marine le pen dans ce foyer fait encore
peur cela semble moins le cas ici
derrière le bar le patron damien 38 ans
et père de deux enfants
quand allez vous cloue figure locale il
détient cinq établissements dans la
ville travaille avec sa femme pauline 70
heures par semaine
emploie 30 salariés ce bon vivant trouve
tout de même le temps de s'occuper du
club de foot de la ferté dimanche
dernier il a déposé un bulletin fillon
dans l'urne pas pour l'homme mais pour
le programme comme bon nombre de ses
clients
il porte un regard désabusé sur la
campagne et la classe politique
c'est que les politiques ou pas les gens
là on va voter quand même les consignes
de vote sur certains qu'il faut c'est un
petit peu ça veut dire que il jouit
aussi malheureusement c'est des français
les gens qui ont voté ce soin extrême
droite ou mélenchon sait les français on
les met de côté ces gens là dimanche
sept mètres on essaie bon tour on ne
sait pas encore décidé je suis un petit
peu déçu parce que le fait que ce fillon
et dit qu'il fallait voter j'aurais
préféré qu'ils disent rien
vous irez soit marine le pen dans ça
m'embêterait un petit peu mais bon ça
serait la première fois peut-être par
bellion juste pour leur faire comprendre
mais bon faut pas que mon âge sinon on
n'aurait pas elle le fait le président
16h15 sortie des classes à l'école
privée catholique saint jean notre dame
nous y croisons jenny venu chercher sa
fille liz et son fils jules génie habite
la ferté-bernard depuis 15 ans lé coach
sportif et accorde beaucoup d'importance
à l'écologie et la solidarité
j'ai voté pour nicolas dupont aignan qui
alors moi je ne suis je suis apolitique
je suis pas vraiment je suis pas plus un
parti que l'autre j'ai été hyper voilà
j'ai énormément lu les problèmes de tout
le monde et c'est la seule personne qui
m'a justement paru être pleine de bon
sens en est puisque son candidat n'est
plus là à emmanuel macron marine le pen
elle préfère un vote blanc ben je reste
fidèle à moi même
voilà en faisant comme ça à quelques
kilomètres de là dans l'orne
la petite commune de val aux perches et
ses trois mille huit cents habitants
au détour des ruelles à deux pas de la
poste et de la mairie une affiche donne
le ton ici on a voté majoritairement
marine le pen au premier tour
le mercredi c'est jour de marché nous
interrompons claude et bernard ont
pleine discussion matinale deux ouvriers
à la retraite au sens de l'humour
ravageur
on est des tamalous voit mal au système
est réelle quand on se lève le matin on
dit amal où les tamalous sont en fait
deux électeurs fillonniste aujourd'hui
déboussolés une chose qui est sûre c'est
qu'on voit tu manges et sec par kéba par
l'un ou par l'autre gars qui veut
supprimer l'europe il ya l'autre qui est
quel candidat des patrons
et donc vous fait quoi entre les deux
j'en sais rien encore et au second tour
vous savez pas j'en sais rien du tout
j'irai voter
mais peut-être blanc autour des étals
les langues se délient pour nous livrer
à peu près tout le même message
les gens en ont marre est le petit
peuple fait partie des oubliés ils sont
là pour représenter le peuple
normalement c'est pour le corps pourrait
secouer tout ça paie tous virés au fil
de nos rencontres
ce qu'il ressort c'est à minima une
compréhension du vote frontiste
ou alors une adhésion pure et simple au
programme de marine le pen et les
électeurs mélenchonistes elles sont
aussi particulièrement courtisés hameau
où jean luc mélenchon est arrivé en tête
du premier tour
beaucoup ne veulent ni le pen ni macro
ils ne veulent pas choisir entre la
peste et le choléra c'est un article à
lire un article de françois vignal elle
pire sur publicsenat.fr
quelle majorité pour gouverner pour
celui qui sera élu dimanche 7 mai la
bataille des législatives sera crucial
sans majorité à l'assemblée nationale
impossible de faire voter des lois et de
mettre en oeuvre les réformes promises
le risque de cohabitation pourrait
fragiliser le prochain quinquennat lors
avant d'en parler avec notre invité
olivier duhamel
voici les explications de géraldine
bavoil où ils sont en plein de bataille
mais une autre les attend celle des
législatives sans majorité au parlement
la règle est simple le ou la présidente
sera condamné à la cohabitation depuis
l'instauration du quinquennat
le parti du candidat élu emportent la
majorité aux élections législatives qui
suivent
mais le risque d'une nouvelle assemblée
fragmenté et sans majorité n'est pas
exclue en cas de victoire la principale
difficulté des manuels macron saura
d'avoir une majorité en marche
pour l'instant son parti n'a investi
qu'une quinzaine de candidats à la
députation
mais il compte sur une coalition avec
d'autres partis pour former un groupe à
l'assemblée nationale marine le pen
nourrit l'ambition de former un groupe
parlementaire front national une
première depuis 1986 un rêve devenu
possible avec un score inédit au premier
tour 84 circonscription place le fn en
tête si elle est élue la candidate soit
aussi organiser un référendum dès son
entrée à l'elysée dont l'une des
propositions serait la réduction de
moins
du nombre de parlementaires emmanuel
macron prendre à lui ses premières
décisions par ordonnance les premiers
pas du futur chef d'état ainsi que les
réactions des partis éliminé au premier
tour seront donc décisifs pour les
législatives est notre invité ce soir
olivier duhamel politologue il répond
aux questions de sa verrière ogec le
face à face et tout de suite
[Musique]
bonjour olivier duhamel alors beaucoup
d'incertitudes un bien sûr autour de
cette future majorité présidentielle est
ce qu'une présidentielle inédite
implique forcément des législatives
inédite
en tout cas cette présidentielle inédite
sans aucun doute parce que quand même on
est dans une situation assez
inimaginable et qui était inconcevable
même encore ya quelques mois on se
retrouve avec deux candidats à la
présidence de la république donc l'un
des deux candidats sera lu par
définition qui n'appartiennent pas à
l'un des deux grands partis qui gouverne
ce pays depuis le début de la vème
république née au parti socialiste et au
parti disant néogaulliste parce qu'il a
pris plusieurs appels la sueur mérité
quand même toujours le même et qui ne
sont ni appartenir sont alliés à une
petite exception giscard d'estaing mais
jusqu'à répondre partis alliés d'autre
part à monsieur pas si c'est le monsieur
qui passe à monsieur que personne ne
connaissait ya trois ans absolument
personne qui n'a pas de force politique
a créé un mouvement dire quoi un an
c'est invraisemblable ou alors si c'est
elle est bien un partie qui certes monte
en puissance par fera qu' aujourd'hui à
3 2 députés à l'assemblée la seconde
alors aussi un quel que soit le
vainqueur
le 7 mai il lui sera difficile bien sûr
de s'appuyer sur une majorité une
majorité de large et stable
quel est votre sentiment là-dessus mon
sentiment
mon dieu d'abord on sait pas voilà c'est
l'honnêteté c'est dire qu'on ne sait
absolument pas qu'est ce qui va sortir
de cette de ces élections législatives
par exemple l'objectif de macron si
c'est lui qui était élu c'est d'avoir
une majorité absolue de son mouvement en
marche éventuellement avec quelques
alliés et il dit mais dans le fond dans
la vème république on a toujours vu sa
bonne m'enfin on a fait ça pour d'abord
n'a pas toujours fait parce qu'ils ont
88 françois mitterrand le parti
socialiste n'avait qu'une majorité
relative et il n'a plus gouverné que par
des majorités variable avec un homme
très talentueux qui s'appelait dit
carcassonne qui étaient à mes profs et
amis et puis qui étaient à la manoeuvre
et dont le concept employés sont cp
tantôt sur sa gauche tantôt sur sa
droite tantôt sur les deux ça faisait
des majorités stéréo tantôt sur tout le
monde ça faisait des majorités sound
ride of hawaii avait ça changeait tout
le temps et d'autre part c'était le
parti socialiste l'a le mouvement marche
je suis sceptique en tout cas la cre on
parle beaucoup
deux coalitions ou même de cohabitation
bien sûr les deux n'ont pas le même
impact sur le fonctionnement des
assemblées qu'il serait l'impact
justement le sur le travail
parlementaire succession parlementaire
ne posait beaucoup beaucoup de questions
en nul en fait
cher sabrina avec beaucoup de questions
en une d'abord nous employons mot
cohabitation bon au moins il faut
accompagner l'accompagner d'un adjectif
parce que c'est quand même vous
admettrez pas du tout la même réalité
politique
une cohabitation imposé en cours de
mandat dans une majorité qui a été
désavoué d'une cohabitation coalition
qu'il aurait choisi woinic d'une
cohabitation a initié au début si c'est
une cohabitation dès le début ça veut
dire que les français disent en même
temps je veux x à la présidence de la
république et je veux qu'ils gouvernent
avec y en même temps donc ça peut pas
être la même répartition du pouvoir que
dans les cohabitations que nous avons
connue en france ou à l inverse
évidemment les trois cohabitations que
nous avons connus ou la totalité du
pouvoir gouvernemental était entre les
mains de l'opposition président donc
première chose si c'est cette situation
disons une cohabitation initial pour
bien la distinguer de l'autre
deuxièmement vous avez raison
cohabitation coalition cohabitation
initial coalition c'est pas la même
chose
dans un cas de figure son mouvement le
mouvement du vainqueur quel qu'il soit
marine le pen ou emmanuel macron n'a pas
la majorité absolue
mais il trouve un deuxième partie voire
deux qui sont d'accord pour former une
coalition
ça se passe après presque à chaque fois
en allemagne par exemple sont assez
courantes dans beaucoup de pays dans la
france monarchiste scénariste et tout ça
ça fait un peu et très étonnant mais
ailleurs c'est très courant et s'il
construit cette coalition
évidemment c'est pas la même situation
que la précédente il a en quelque sorte
plus de pouvoir est ce que ce sera l'un
ou l'autre ni vous ni moi ni personne ne
peut le dire
bien sûr aujourd'hui à emmanuel macron
affirme sans cire qui disposera d'une
majorité absolue il exclut tout accord
avec le parti socialiste jean christophe
cambadelis là encore mise en garde
récemment contre qui se présente dix ans
et alyse assez vite parce qu'avant il
parlait pas comme ça ils changent déjà
il est déjà contaminé par la cinquième à
la emmanuel macron veut
passé par des ordonnances est ce qu'une
majorité parlementaire fragile justement
ne va pas l'empêcher de gouverner de
cette façon dans les premiers temps de
son mandat de son hypothétique wanda
bien sûr alors vous continuez à me
demander à prévoir l'impossible ce que
je peux vous dire de part de mon métier
c'est que là où on a le plus gouverner
par ordonnance
c'était en 1967 le premier ministre de
l'époque était georges pompidou et c'est
parce que la majorité était très courte
donc quand la majorité quand la majorité
très large
c'est plus difficile d'imposer à sa
majorité par ordonnance parce qu'on dit
à l'écouté vous avez la majorité c'est
pas la peine de venir nous en vue de
devenir daigné notre bois quand la
majorité est très étroite et est fragile
on peut dire si vous ne me permettait
pas de gouverner par nans je ne pourrais
pas agir et l'obtenir donc la
corrélation si elle existe elle est plus
avec majorité étroite qu'avec majorité
large s'avoue vin comme un pont qui
compte c'est lui ment on parle beaucoup
en ce moment de recomposition politique
de recomposition du paysage politique en
tout cas est ce que justement cette
recomposition et passe pas par un
gouvernement de coalition c'était leur
pari de l'alliance justement alors
parlons des manuels vaqueront avec les
centristes ans dans le cas d' emmanuel
macron ou avec les républicains dans le
cas de marine le pen
oui pourquoi vous avez raison et
pourquoi
avant tout était très simple on était
dans un quasi bipartisme alors vous
aviez une élection à deux tours au
deuxième tour seulement deux candidats à
la présidentielle souvent aux
législatives seulement des duels
puis un camp gagné gouverner rien de
plus simple on est passé du bipartisme
autres y participent avec la montée et
l'installation du front national on est
passé du tripartisme aux quadri partisme
avec la division très forte de la gauche
entre la gauche de la gauche et la
gauche sous françois hollande est avec
le premier tour on est passé du quad
répartition pintât a party smpp à ce que
vous avez maintenant une force autonome
qui s'appelle en marche et le modem au
centre qui n'est plus une chose
marginale chose important donc on est
passé en quelques mots on peut de temps
d'un quasi biparti au pintât partie sac
comment on fait quand on a cinq parties
et que personne n'a la majorité dans
fait ce que font nos amis allemands
nos amis allemands ils sont passés comme
nous de 2 à 3 à 4 à 5 cd ou spd était
censé arriver où est la quatrième et les
libéraux mais on est aidé en feront
baisser cette troisième force
elle a refait mais vous avez parcouru le
monde vous êtes jeunes arrêtés avec le
fantôme de la quatrième république
et regardez plutôt ce qui se passe chez
nos voisins qui sont dans cette
situation nous sommes au 21ème siècle
c'est pas parce que sous la quatrième
république
ça n'a pas fonctionné mais pour beaucoup
d'autres raisons et pas seulement pour
ça qu'il faut qu'on se dit sur la base
c'est l'horreur c'est la ive république
fait six mois que c'est l'horreur mais
laissez moi puis nassim d'instabilité
parlementaire alors laissez moi finir
sur ma référence à l'allemagne si vous
voulez bien d'accord 1 ils sont passés
de deux à trois avec les libéraux de 3 à
4 avec les verts de 4 à 5 avec die linke
ils ont le même problème que nous dans
ten dam affaiblissement des deux grands
et de la multiplication des partis
qu'est ce qu'ils font quand il ya une
élection le parti vainqueur c'est son
chef qui vient chancelier comme non un
président toutes choses égales par
ailleurs donc merkel mais ils font une
coalition avec un deuxième partie ils se
réunissent pendant deux mois
les gens savent pas sale p pas en deux
mois et de quoi il parle il parle pas
des postes et posters iv en trois jours
d'ailleurs il ya des règles qui se sont
quasiment des coutumes le numéro 2 le
chef du deuxième parti devient numéro
2010 affaires étrangères vous savez york
ap 6h etc a maintenant l'autre là bon
ils discutent de ce qu'ils vont faire
pendant la législature est ce qu'on
ferme les centrales nucléaires ont pas
et combien est-ce qu'on instaure le smic
quel genre de smic et ses textes à une
fois qu'ils sont d'accord sur un
programme et gouverne et ça marche
si vous pensez qu'on est capable de
gouverner comme ça en france bah il
faudra bien il faudra bien voyez je vais
terminer 2
provoquer l'implosion cérébrale encore
des gens qui font référence à la ivème
république je pense que la condition
maintenant pour que ça marche avec 5 au
lieu de deux la condition pour que ça
marche c'est la proportionnelle
la proportionnelle est devenu ce qui
peut redonner de la gouvernabilité de la
capacité à gouverner au pouvoir exécutif
sur la vème république évidemment pour
nous c'est très perturbant à la
proportionnelle donnerait
30 % de députées front national à
l'assemblée nationale eh oui alors ça
vous dérange
je n'ai pas d'opinion personnelle depuis
les coulisses il ya françois vernay de
cette façon là à écouter ici d'abord sa
langue c'est pas parce qu'ils auraient
30% débuté front national que l'on peut
pas faire une coalition entre 6 et pas
le front national qui a gagné l'élection
présidentielle on peut veut peut faire
on peut presque plus facilement faire
une coalition s'il ya beaucoup de
formations de reste très peu de temps
françois mitterrand disait les
institutions sont dangereuses elles
l'étaient avant moi elles le seront
après moi vous êtes d'accord avec ça les
institutions sont dangereux je pense que
d'abord c'est une phrase hallucinante
quand même françois mitterrand nous en a
sorti beaucoup mais celle-là du genre
moi ça va et les autres c'est l'horreur
il ya jamais poussé aussi loin
dangereuses non dangereuse qu'est ce
qu'ils ont dangereusement ils ont fait
de mal à personne les institutions sont
des institutions originale un peu
bizarre compliqué qu'il faut adapter
quand on a des situations nouvelles mais
elles ne sont pas dangereuses dans
l'ansé de tout ce qu'a dit françois
mitterrand c'est nice cad mieux nice 4
plus démocratique nice y est plus vrai
enfin finir un mot si vous deviez
qualifié cette campagne délirante
bah oui la plus folle de toute la plus
folle de tout pour le pire et pour le
meilleur
merci beaucoup merci olivier duhamel
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci
merci olivier duhamel merci savaria ont
continué bien le direct sur public sénat
présidentielle 360 le rappel des titres
à la campagne sans relâche de marine le
pen sur le terrain après les inner wheel
pour le damian hier la candidate fn
était ce matin au chevet des pêcheurs au
grau-du-roi dans le gard avant un grand
meeting ce soir à nice où seront en
direct dans un instant et pendant ce
temps emmanuel macron cherche lui aussi
à faire campagne dans les territoires
oubliés
il était cet après midi à sarcelles en
seine-saint-denis pour faire taire les
critiques
une campagne tardive reportage à suivre
que vont faire les fillonnistes et les
mélenchonistes c'est un électorat très
disputée comment vont-ils reporter leur
voix quel niveau pour l'abstention
ce sera le thème du second débat de
cette édition
et je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
réagir à cette émission sur twitter avec
le hashtag présidentielle à 360 pour
m'accompagner ce soir jusqu'à 19 heures
30 quand un calme et en direct de nice
le multiplex s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
tulisa l'instant marine le pen enchaîne
les déplacements après la visite
surprise des ouvriers grévistes damien
la candidate frontiste était dès potron
minet en mer avec les pêcheurs du grau
du roi pour un discours axé sur le
protectionnisme et l'europe avant un
grand meeting à nice flore sauvages les
sondages la donnent toujours battu au
second tour de la présidentielle mais
marine le pen ne lâche rien devant les
caméras dès potron minet elle part en
mer avec les pêcheurs de grau du roi
dans le gard et la candidate tacle
emmanuel macron qui ont rejoint un
concurrent qui ne supporte pas le terme
de pénibilité pourtant
les métiers qui sont extrêmement pénible
et je crois que le métier de vingt
pêcheurs fait partie de ces métiers sont
très pénibles et puis mérite que le
fruit du travail qu'on en tire soit la
hauteur de
d'efforts que vont occuper le terrain
médiatique tout en allant à la rencontre
des français
une stratégie qui semble payer puisque
l'écart se resserre entre les deux
concurrents
emmanuel macron perd quatre points dans
un sondage aux hawks a diffusé
aujourd'hui plus de travail le trader
c'est le travail de ses amis des grandes
orgues des grandes puissances
financières on voit bien d'ailleurs le
plus grand mal à parler à la france qui
travaille et la bataille médiatique se
fait aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
le fondateur dans marche s'est empressé
de commenter la sortie en mer de marine
le pen ce matin madame le pen se promène
à la pêche
bonne promenade la sortie de l'europe
qu'elle propose c'est la fin de la pêche
française
pensez-y ce soir à nice marine le pen
réuni ses soutiens autour d'elle pour
son premier meeting de l'entré deux
tours objectif convaincre les électeurs
de droite alors même que le président de
la région paca christian estrosi appelle
à faire barrage au front national en
votant pour emmanuel macron et on
retrouve à présent un tamm tran huy sam
on passe à la loupe avec vous les propos
des candidats dans cette campagne mais
aussi de leur soutien on s'intéresse ce
soir aux propos de marion maréchal-le
pen à la députée qui a défendu les
mesures protectionnistes voulue par le
fn alors on les coupe tout de suite je
parle d'entreprises qui ferment des
usines en france pour les mettre dans
des pays à bas coûts salariaux comme la
pologne pour ensuite réimporter s'est
produit sur le marché français eh bien
nous disons à ces entreprises et nous le
ferons que si elles font le choix de
cette caste sociale si elles font le
choix de cette ineptie écologique et
bien elles devront s'attendre à être
frappé de taxes à l'importation pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de bénéfice à la
délocalisation alors je tiens quand même
à préciser parce que c'est assez amusant
qu'en parallèle la pologne il ya
quelques mois de cela avait passé un
contrat avec airbus pour une commande de
50 hélicoptères lorsque le gouvernement
eurosceptique est arrivée aux affaires
il a en toute violation du droit
européen rompu son contrat pour choisir
un autre fournisseur qui est un
fournisseur américain qui lui va
produire par les usines polonaises par
tam la proposition de marine le pen de
créer une taxe à l'importation jusqu'à
35% pour les entreprises qui
délocalisent et réimportent leurs
produits en france
est-ce que c'est contraire au droit
européen bien sûr ça chez deux pays
européens comme
c'est le cas pour la pologne dans le
cadre la poule eh bien ce n'est
effectivement pas possible comme le dit
à l'intervieweuse dans l'émission de ce
matin car c'est contraire au principe du
marché unique qui a supprimé les droits
de douane et toutes les taxes
équivalente
donc il est impossible de mettre en
place une telle taxe
quand on parle d'une entreprise
installée en france qui choisit de délai
quiz et de délocaliser dans un autre
pays européen c'est donc contraire au
droit européen
effectivement mais que vaut cette
comparaison un keuf et marion
maréchal-le pen avec la sphère des
hélicoptères que la pologne on s'en
souvient devait commander auprès
d'airbus
la pologne qui a finalement choisi le
constructeur américain d'un certain on
se rappelle que c'était la douche froide
1 pour la france et airbus ne de perdre
un tel contrat c'était quand même 50
hélicoptères militaires un contrat
d'environ 3 milliards d'euros et
d'ailleurs il s'en est suivi une
véritable crise diplomatique entre paris
et varsovie
à tel point que la france a imaginé des
mesures de rétorsion se rappelle aussi
qu airbus a voulu attaquer auprès de
bruxelles pour demander des
compensations financières pour les
préjudices subis
en effet le savez déjà fait des
investissements mais tout ça ça n'a pas
grand chose à voir avec le droit
européen qui n'empêche pas un pays de
préférer une entreprise à une autre d'un
petit une entreprise étrangère une
entreprise américaine par rapport à une
entreprise européenne même si cela ne va
pas dans le sens bien sûr de l'europe de
la défense
à ce niveau là donc l'argumentation de
marion maréchal-le pen est inexact
est ce que ce sont pour des raisons
protectionnistes que varsovie a préféré
le constructeur américain à l'européen
airbus
là encore on peut en douter cité
l'argumentation un des polonais ils ont
plaidé en disant que les compensations
industrielles prévu par airbus n'était
pas à la hauteur
il faut dire aussi que le gouvernement
polonais à l'époque avait réclamé des
conditions absolument impossibles à
satisfaire du point de vue des experts
des conditions jamais vu il fallait qu
airbus qui injecte 100 % de la valeur du
contrat dans le pays en investissements
industriels et transferts de technologie
est d'ailleurs derrière bus était allé
aussi loin que possible et a tenté de le
prouver par la suite
en réalité ce qui arrive et c'est un
changement politique en pologne oui
effectivement en octobre 2015 le parti
ultra conservateur eurosceptique droit
et justice prend les rênes du pays et
donc il prévoit elle privilégie donc
l'américain lockheed martin tout d'abord
un parce que c'est un parti
eurosceptique
et qui ne veut pas entendre parler
d'airbus ensuite parce que les usines en
pologne du constructeur américain se
trouve dans les circonscriptions de ses
députés ultra conservateur et puis enfin
on peut penser qu'il y a eu la pression
diplomatique de l'amérique
et dans ce contexte de fortes tensions
en fait entre la pologne et la russie
sur un fond de crise et craignent n est
bien la pologne a préféré privilégier le
parapluie américain par rapport à
l'europe de la défense
en résumé le tam et bien marion
maréchal-le pen a donc doublement otor
la décision de la pologne d'avoir
recours à un constructeur américain
pensée elle dans militaire n'est pas
contraire au droit européen et par
ailleurs si la pologne après cette
décision ce n'est pas pour des raisons
protectionnistes mais pour des raisons
politiques et diplomatiques
merci beaucoup uttam pour toutes ces
précisions voilà pour la campagne de
marine le pen on s'intéresse maintenant
à celle d'emmanuel macron car dans ce
duel à distance entre les deux
finalistes
le candidat en marche a choisi d'occuper
le terrain de la banlieue avec un
déplacement dans ces territoires oubliés
dont le vote pourrait jouer un rôle clé
dimanche 7 mai il était à sarcelles
aujourd'hui c'est celle 6 au 17 fi des
demandes d'autographes
oki détour à sarcelles l'accueil est
plus chaleureux qu'à amiens hier
dans la bataille de l'image emmanuel
macron est désormais offensif en rendant
visite à une association d'insertion par
le sport
le candidat dans marche s'impose sur le
terrain et reprend la main sur la
campagne pour ne plus se laisser
distancer dans la compétition par marine
le pen
la france ça n'est pas ce visage haineux
et rétrécit que par madame le pen je ne
la laisserai pas porter ce visage de la
france je ne la laisserai pas banaliser
ce qu'est le parti du front national est
un parti xénophobe
elle a mené à la tête de ce parti
quelqu'un qui a eu des positions
extraordinairement grave
le candidat dans marche est également
venu chercher chez eux
les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon à
sarcelles le candidat de la france
insoumise afrique 30% les voix au
premier tour des élections
présidentielles et on continue le débat
sur public sénat avec mes invités qui
m'ont rejoint sur ce plateau et marie
cann bonsoir directeur des études
politiques à l'institut elad merci
d'être avec nous florian sin qui est
également sur ce plateau bonsoir jette
un fondateur et directeur associé de
l'agencé de communication à la french
com merci d'être avec nous olivier
rouquan bonsoy politologue chercheur
associé au servage fait le centre
d'études et de recherches de sciences
administratives et de politique
et puis tristan kino maupoil bonsoir
êtes journaliste politique au figaro on
va s'intéresser ce soir à ce réservoir
de voix que constitue à la fois les
électeurs mélenchonistes et fillonniste
yves marie cann est ce que pour
l'instant on peut dire eh bien qu'ils
ont choisi la position à adopter pour le
second tour ap ap à tous en tout cas
pour certains en tout cas les électeurs
mélenchonistes n'y a pas de position
aujourd'hui officiel donc chacun fait un
peu ce qu'il veut mais si on se base sur
les dernières enquêtes d'intentions va
de réaliser on voit que les électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon sont tiraillés d'une
certaine façon entre un vote macron où
l'abstention et le vote blanc nul
et puis on a quand même quelques
électeurs qui se réfugient ray quand
même vers vers marine le pen
du côté de françois fillon s'est pas
beaucoup plus clair on en a certains sur
deux de ses électeurs qui partirait sur
emmanuel macron mais le reste se
répartit à parts égales entre marine le
pen et l'abstention ou le vote blanc nul
donc on voit bien que là il ya quand
même
quelqu'un décision des tiraillements qui
se font jour à travers ses résultats et
bien entendu ces lignes la et bien elles
peuvent bouger sous l'effet de la
campagne électorale c'est sans doute
aussi la raison pour laquelle on voit
bien que dans les premiers sondages
d'après premier tour qui ont été
réalisés depuis lundi on voit qu'on
n'observe pas ma resserrement du rapport
de force entre emmanuel macron et marine
le pen est donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
aussi des électeurs des candidats
éliminés qu'ils sont en train de
basculer vers la candidate du front
national très tranquille au moins voilà
prêt d'avoir tendu la main aux électeurs
de jean luc mélenchon on voit que marine
le pen un présent et bien mise sur
l'électorat de la droite traditionnelle
catholique elle est ce soir elle était
aujourd'hui dans la région paca est la
raison de s'adresser à cette partie des
électeurs qui pourraient être tentés à
de voter pour elle au second tour elle a
cette capacité de s'adresser à la fois
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon est à
la fois l'électorat françois fillon
parce qu'aujourd'hui le clivage ce n'est
plus la gauche contre la droite c'est le
clivage entre les personnes les
personnes qui profitent de la
mondialisation et ceux qui en sont les
victimes est à la fois dans l'électorat
de jean luc mélenchon est à la fois dans
l'électorat de françois fillon
on retrouve ces thématiques jean luc
mélenchon il fait ses bons scores chez
les jeunes dans le nord dans l'est
voici là où les terres du front national
sont fortes et chez françois fillon on a
entendu dans son discours le thème de la
souveraineté qui est extrêmement fort et
qui est également dans le discours de
marine le pen
donc elle peut à la fois s'attaquer à
ces deux électorats elle peut aborder
second tour sur deux tableaux est ce que
c'est le même cas de figure pour
emmanuel macron à ce qu'il peut aussi
capter à la fois l'électorat de jean luc
mélenchon et celui de françois fillon
au delà du front républicain olivier
rouquan oui je pense que les l'affairé
est moins nette que ce qui vient d'être
dit sur l'électorat de jean luc
mélenchon dont on peut constater à
travers quelques enquêtes d'opinion que
il est moins protectionnistes il est
moins fermé par rapport à l'union
européenne qu'on ne le dit c'est à dire
que vous avez quand même une majorité
dans l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon
aujourd'hui qui ne veut pas de la france
quitte union européenne vous avez une
plus d'un gros tiers qui pensent que la
mondialisation est une chance pour la
france
et l'écart sur cette question entre les
tu auras de jean-luc mélenchon et celui
de emmanuel macron est plus faible que
celui entre son électorat dont celui de
marine le pen dans les vases
communicants potentiel tout ceci est
véritablement de l'ordre des
probabilités un raisonnement termes de
probabilités les vases communicants
entre jean luc mélenchon et emmanuel
macron semble plus aisé que celui entre
jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen pour
cette raison et puis pour des raisons
historiques et dans le crash déjà les
dires du projet l'idéologie de jean luc
mélenchon se son histoire de son
parcours qui même si cette fois ci
décide de ne pas donner de consigne de
vote indique bien quand même que la
proximité entre sur l'électorat et celui
d' emmanuel macron est a priori plus
aisés florian est cynique il aurait tort
emmanuel macron de tout vouloir miser
sur le front républicain on voit que
cette idée finalement à durer peut-être
l'espace de 24 heures
ici il a vite été désillusionnés à cet
égard il s'est vite aperçu que la vague
sur lequel il comptait sur fait du front
républicain elle le mène à elle beaucoup
moins loin que ce qu'il avait prévu et
anticipé et autant emmanuel macron que
marine le pen aujourd'hui ils doivent
faire face au fond à la chasse à ces
voix qui sont celles de la colère de ses
électeurs et pour cela il faut trouver
les mots justes et sans apparaître comme
le candidat du grand écart trop
incohérent et donc au fond trop peu
naturel et sincère pour convaincre les
derniers électeurs en tout cas pour les
plus indécis par ailleurs quant à la
position de jean luc mélenchon il faut
quand même rappeler qu en 97 il nous dit
il faut interdire le front national par
une loi
aujourd'hui enfin en 2002 il nous dit
évidemment il faut marginalisés marine
le pen aujourd'hui il nous dit je m'en
remets à mes électeurs avec une méthode
qui rappelle celle de beppe grillo et
son mouvement 5 étoiles le vote internet
on va voir ce que ça donne mais ça
paraît quand même être une évolution qui
dit beaucoup de la perception du front
national dans notre société et ilmari
cannes il y aura aussi bien la question
des abstentionnistes ans a été évoqué au
cours de nos reportages certains et bien
refuse à aller voter on voit avec ce
sentiment aussi de dunes
ni le pen ni macron qui est en train de
se propager chez les jeunes les lycéens
qui manifestent aujourd'hui dans la rue
oui effectivement et c'est là qu'on voit
bien quand même qu'elle est où le
contraste entre aujourd'hui et ce qui
s'est passé il ya il ya quinze ans parce
qu'il ya 15 ans et elle en était en
avril 2001 donc la qualification
surprise de jean luc mélenchon pour le
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
et l'entre-deux tour avait été marqué
par de très nombreuses manifestations
alors certes aujourd'hui il ya quelques
manifestations
enfin société contre jean marie le pen
pardon mais c'est vrai que le degré
d'émotion et quand même nettement moins
élevé qu'il ne l'était il y a quinze ans
et c'est vrai que par conséquent on a
aussi beaucoup d'électeurs qui hésitent
beaucoup à jouer la carte du front
républicain ou en tout cas à voter pour
emmanuel macron pour faire barrage à
marine le pen
ça c'est très clair et c'est donc un
indicateur qui va falloir surveiller de
très près à savoir le potentiel de
participation au second tour qui
aujourd'hui tel qu'il est mesuré
aujourd'hui est inférieur à ce que l'on
mesurait quelques jours avant le premier
tour c'est déjà une première information
et puis surtout on va sans doute
connaître un record plus de votes blancs
et nuls
à l'occasion de cette élection votes
blancs et nuls qui avait déjà atteint un
niveau très élevé il faut le rappeler en
2012 parce qu'il avait lorsqu'il s'était
lorsqu'il s'était agi de choisir entre
nicolas sarkozy et françois hollande ya
vu plus de plusieurs plus d'un million
de votes blancs et nuls cette fois ci ça
risque effectivement d'être très élevé
signe effectivement de l'indécision du
refus de choisir effectivement entre ces
deux candidatures
alors on va continuer l'analyse et le
débat avec vous messieurs mais je vous
propose de retrouver quand un cas mais
puisqu'il est en direct de nice où
marine le pen a doit s'exprimer d'ici
une demi-heure quentin vous êtes au
palais nikaïa en compagnie du sénateur
maire frontiste de fréjus david rachline
c'est à vous
david rachline sénateur maire de fréjus
direct la campagne de marine le pen lors
quel message de la candidate ce soir ici
à nice en terre de droite
oui un message de rassemblement parce
que elle a fait un excellent résultat au
premier tour mais nous bénéficions
aujourd'hui d'une belle dynamique
une belle dynamique de campagne les
premiers jours de la campagne se sont
d'ailleurs extrêmement bien passé il
faut bien le dire en tout cas pour nous
et nous voulons rassembler les français
sur l'idée de choisir la france de
choisir en toute circonstance lorsque
nous serons responsabilité l'intérêt de
la france l'intérêt du peuple français
quand le schéma qu on le choisira
l'intérêt du medef l'intérêt de l'union
européenne
l'intérêt parfois même des
communautarismes de l'unef le discours
de ce soir
quels sont les grands axes cet axe là de
choisir la france encore une fois la
volonté de rassembler les français
autour de l'idée qu'il faut que la
france soit au coeur de l'action
publique
je crois que c'est ça le vrai clivage en
fait un le clivage entre nous et
messieurs macron c'est précisément celui
ci quand il est le candidat du
mondialisme acharné de la mondialisation
sauvage de l'ultralibéralisme de
l'européisme fou de l'accélération de la
politique de monsieur hollande nous
sommes et marine est la candidate du
patriotisme retrouver toujours aucun
ralliement de poids ce stade dans la
campagne on attend toujours la décision
de monsieur dupont aignan est ce que
vous l'attendez aussi c'est pas le
problème le problème ce n'est pas les
différentes personnes en particulier à
droite qui ont trahi leurs électeurs et
qui se précipitent dans les jupes de
monsieur macron après l'avoir rappelé
emmanuel hollande devant la campagne ça
ça ne trompe personne la réalité c'est
que nous aujourd'hui nous sommes en
dynamique électorale en dynamique de
popularité même parce que je sais que
marine a augmenté fortement ces jours ci
sa popularité
c'est la démonstration qu'elle est
capable de rassembler je crois qu'elle
le fera le soir du second tour très
largement et d'aller en question est ce
qu a pas une contradiction à vouloir
parler à la droite ce soir et six ans en
terre voilà niçoise qui sont des terres
sarkozyste et puis être chez whirlpool
ou à rungis en début de semaine vous
pensez que
les gens de droite veulent que nos
entreprises s'en aille
moi je crois au contraire qu'il peut y
avoir aussi bien chez les salariés que
chez les ouvriers que chez les cadres
une volonté politique d'un patriotisme
retrouver pour faire enfin en sorte
qu'on change de modèle économique qu'on
puisse faire du patriotisme économique
qu'on puisse faire du protectionnisme
intelligent qu'on puisse protéger les
français protéger nos entreprises
protéger nos emplois c'est notre
objectif et ça je crois que c'est
transcourants ça peut rassembler tous
les français
merci beaucoup david rachline c'est un
terreau maire de fréjus ici un pour
cette interview à nice merci beaucoup
quentin tristan kinomap wallon vient
d'entendre effectivement ce discours
attendu de marine le pen qui va
s'adresser à cette droite qui est
partagée ans a été rappelé la fois par
christian estrosi qui a tout de suite
appelé à voter emmanuel macron eric
ciotti et qui le patron du département
c'était peut-être un peu plus compliquée
de son côté elle peut chercher des voix
dans cette incertitude des dirigeants de
droite appelé clairement à voter manuela
concertée victimes de marine le pen ce
soir à nice il se passe au palais nikaïa
c'est dans cette même salle que françois
fillon a tenu son meeting l'un de ses
derniers meetings c'était à alice aussi
et on se souvient de christian estrosi
qui monte à la tribune juste un an
françois fillon et qui délivre une
charge extrêmement violentes contre
marine le pen contre le front national
et la salle le u
la salle lui demande de se taire alors
évidemment certains lui en voulaient
d'avoir d'avoir reçu emmanuel macron
avant mais c'est aussi parce que dans
cette salle
certains militants considèrent que
marine le pen n'est pas un danger est
certain c'est une évidence nous voterons
pour elle dans le sud de la france c'est
l'un des bastions du front national et
une porosité comme ça qui existe entre
le front national et les républicains
donc si elle va ce soir à essayer de
conquérir cet électorat ce n'est pas un
hasard
dans cette région on sait bien et depuis
longtemps depuis les années 90 même un
peu avant il y à une porosité comme vous
dites d'abord c'était une course d
accord un dirigeant avec des accords des
alliances ensuite des électorats tout
ceci a été préparée largement renforcée
par l'orientation nicolas sarkozy sur la
sécurité
on voit aujourd'hui dans l'électorat de
françois fillon une des motivations du
vote fillon c'est justement le
terrorisme
la sécurité évidemment on retrouve une
parenté dans les motivations de vote
même si c'est encore plus fort chez dans
l'explication de vote pour marine le pen
dont oui elle cette porosité exit mais
il faut aussi regarder que dans le même
électorat fillon alors dans d'autres
régions sans doute il y à une thématique
de vote qui a été la lutte contre le
chômage est également le redressement de
l'économie la lutte contre la dette
et là on va plutôt pouvoir imaginer une
possible un compromis avec emmanuel
macron et là encore avec un vote motiver
une deux thèmes qu'on retrouve chez
fillon et chez makro c'est préparer
l'europe de demain
donc on voit que les républicains sur
ces questions se départagent florian
ceni qui s'était évoqué par contre un
calme et pour marine le pen il ya aussi
cet enjeu bien de pouvoir rallier de
pouvoir récupérer
les voix de nicolas dupont aignan
quasiment 5% sas est une aussi une des
chansons pour elle de se qualifier au
second tour
vous avez raison il faut qu elle leur
parle aussi elle la difficulté au fond
aujourd'hui pour marine le pen elle
c'est de montrer qu'elle est capable de
confronter et d'affronter emmanuel
macron que tous les sondages ont d'ores
et déjà désigné pour le moment malgré le
resserrement des différences entre eux
comme celui qui sortira vainqueur de
cette élection présidentielle il s'agit
donc pour elle de démontrer qu'il est
assez faible sur certains points et la
visite de word poule a été une sorte de
dépucelage social pour emmanuel macron
et surtout la projeter dans second tour
assez violemment alors que sa compagne
avait totalement de calais il faut
aujourd'hui que ces deux candidats
démontre au fond un appui sur les points
de faiblesse qui sont révélés par cette
campagne chez l'autre candidat pour
convaincre les indécis potentiel alors
que l'opinion au fond est aussi et mon
confrère ne dira sans doute assez
indécis quant à elle est un des six
convois en banlieue comme cet après midi
à sarcelles il cible quels types
d'électeurs les abstentionnistes puisque
ça on peut pas dire et bien que la une
d'un réservoir de voix peut être à la
fois ouais c'est ce qui est certain
c'est qu'on n'est pas là pour le coup il
n'est pas sur des terres qui se sont
massivement déplacés dans les bureaux de
vote dimanche
dimanche formé en qui en revanche ont
quand même quand on a voté ont voté pour
jean luc mélenchon est donc là pour le
coup effectivement il y a un intérêt
pour emmanuel macron allait envoyer des
signaux à cet électorat là pour
récupérer un électorat dont on imagine
mal qu'il se reporteraient aujourd'hui
sur la candidature de marine le pen
compte tenu de ce qui reste la structure
d'image du front national et de marine
le pen aujourd'hui dans au sein de la
population française mais que son ami
romaric le directeur de campagne de
marine le pen ne parle plus de marine le
pen il parle de marine le pen a disparu
d'ailleurs de la fif de campagne de la
candidate du front national c'est un
signe parce que effectivement ils savent
bien que pour aller chercher les voix
qui leur manque
il faut se débarrasser d'un certain
nombre effectivement d'attributs qui
sont autant de handicaps parce que même
si l'image du front national a beaucoup
s'est beaucoup améliorée au cours de ces
dernières années
il n'empêche qu'on a toujours une très
large majorité de français de l'ordre de
60% qui déclare ne pas partager les
idées du front national
déclare n'avoir jamais voté pour le
front national et ne pas avoir
l'intention de voter pour le front
national et donc ça c'est comme un
handicap majeur aujourd'hui pour la
candidature de marine le pen et c'est
sans doute aussi la raison pour laquelle
en tout cas politique d'un point de vue
politique il sera sans doute très
difficile pour elle de faire la bascule
au soir du second tour
tu restes en petit nombre elle
s'accompagne cette affiche de campagne
cette nouvelle affiche qui a été révélée
hier par les équipes de marine le pen
elle mise aussi beaucoup sur cette image
de femme de mère de famille ça ça peut
séduire aussi une partie de l'électorat
traditionnel de droite ou de messages
sur cette affiche à la fois l'un sévère
à ses à regard assez sévère c'est dur et
puis il ya ce bout de deux jambes qui
apparaît qui a interloqué un petit peu
les internautes moquer parfois mais
c'est aussi sa féminité qu'elle met en
avant donc est à la fois ce message de
sécurité et à la fois deux de douceur je
sais pas mais en tout cas moi il ya deux
de deux symboles qui sont qui sont
envoyées et elle joue sur sur ses
tableaux dames et justement sur cet
aspect mère de famille elle insiste
beaucoup et à la taxe notamment aux
emmanuel macron sur ce point comment
vous l'expliquez ça olivier rouquan le
lécher la ford par l'image et plus par
le discours évidemment de récupérer
l'électorat de la droite classique donc
la posture sur la famille la rapprochant
plus de marion maréchal-le pen et puis
de indirectement de françois fillon et
son électorat on sait très bien
d'ailleurs qu'auprès de l'électorat
catholique pratiquant le front national
fn alors que celui de françois fillon
est très fort donc elle trouve des
billets symbolique pour pour essayer de
l'accrocher sur la famille maintenant si
on revient à cette affiche
elle est un peu clivé cette affiche
parce que la bibliothèque rappelle
j'allais presque dire la symbolique
mitterrandienne ou même gaullienne c'est
ça rappelle la l'entrée en fonctions à
l'elysée les portraits officiels la
bibliothèque en arrière plan et d'un
autre côté on a la femme j'allais
presque dire cadres ou cadres supérieurs
de mai de ce point de vue là encore ça
correspond pas à son électorat cette
posture et j'allais presque dire cette
tenue donc c'est juste pour les larges
je pense que c'est un des moyens pour
essayer d'élargir on risque d'avoir une
communication quand même paradoxal par
rapport à ce qu'elle a fait et donc par
rapport à la mémoire de son image
jusqu'à présent ça brouille les cartes
au contraire ça lui donne une dimension
présidentielle présidence saab selon
vous florian foot mais à partir du
moment où vous êtes dans une stratégie à
tracts où vous prenez le risque évident
d'être totalement incohérente et de ne
pas atteindre les objectifs que vous
avez fixé
c'est le cas de cette affiche qui
franchement mise à la fois sur le côté
il n'y a pas besoin de mettre le pen
parce que les français connaît son
visage et savent au fond identifiées
donc et pas besoin de préciser mais dans
le même temps on vous dit on va leur et
où tenter de leurrer une partie des
français parce qu'il y aura pas le nom
de famille et sa vallée la démarquer du
père et des attributs du front national
d'ailleurs on ne retrouve pas les codes
franchement c'est totalement c'est une
stratégie au fond qui est incohérente
par structure par nature ou ont choisi
là où on choisit l'autre est là au fond
on fait tous les choix et ça posera sans
doute une difficulté un autre petit
tristan qui sont pas pouvoir ce sont ses
mains on voit que ça à la fois sa main
gauche et droite se tiennent les n'a pas
une qui prend le dessus sur l'autre
ça rappelle aussi la fiche de françois
bayrou en 2007 il y avait on le
connaissait en homme de droite plutôt
françois bayrou il prenait sa main
droite et sa main gauche l'enveloppé
c'est aussi un symbole pour montrer que
c'est le ni droite ni gauche etc ça
correspond voilà des signaux ambivalent
qui sont envoyées sur cette fiche jeu
pour essayer d'être à tout justement
emmanuel macron est ce qu'il n'est pas
aussi attrape-tout alors vous n'êtes pas
quand on affiche mais aussi les jo cette
carte
oui bien sûr et d'ailleurs si quand on
regarde quel est son électorat au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ont remis à son électorat
est extrêmement hétérogène et donc
effectivement ville a une dimension
attrape-tout dès le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle qui se vérifie
notamment contrairement à marine le pen
par ces bons résultats sont relativement
bons résultats toutes classes d'âge
confondues il fait de bons d'assez bons
scores chez les jeunes il arrive en
deuxième position d'après les
différentes enquêtes réalisées au
premier tour derrière jean-luc mélenchon
donc ça veut dire que marine le pen a
été rétrogradé en troisième position
auprès des plus jeunes
et dans le même temps il fait le 23
avril de meilleurs résultats qu'attendu
auprès des plus âgés
c'est à dire qu'il talonne de très près
france
françois fillon est donc finalement il a
quand même une structure générationnel
en termes de soutien et en terme
d'électeurs qui est assez homogène et ça
c'est quand même une force c'est ce qui
est fait c'est ce qui fait finalement sa
première position au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle et puis après
on voit bien que certains aient le
clivage la mondialisation heureuse la
mondialisation malheureuse en fait quand
on regarde la carte électorale il ya
quand même des certains certes un
élément de nuance à introduire parce
qu'on voit quand même que certains
clivages rural urbain
si on pense à son score notamment à
paris l'agglomération parisienne
vis-à-vis d'autres territoires ruraux
même temps si vous regardez les scores
des manades macron dans le quart
nord-ouest du pays et notamment en
bretagne et pays de loire
vous voyez que le clivage rural urbain
il tient plus la route et que la
bretagne elle peut aussi elle a aussi de
très bonnes raisons aujourd'hui de se
plaindre de la mondialisation et
pourtant on sait que ce sont des terres
qui reste quand même très ouvert à
l'union européen très ouverte à l'union
européenne et qui se sont massivement
portés sur la candidature d'emmanuel
macron olivier rouquan on évoquait ce
mouvement de ni-ni ni le pen ni macron
qui est en train est bien de se mettre
en place notamment au niveau des jeunes
des primo votants est ce que ea les deux
candidats finalistes sont inquiétés oui
singulière du fait de ce l'absence des
deux partis du gouvernement du fait
également de d'une moindre perception de
j'allais dire du projet de l'un comme de
l'autre
dire que ce sont des candidats alors
attrape tout qui se communique beaucoup
j'allais dire sur le mode de très
symbolique mais qui ne vont pas ou font
des pressions sur le comment faire on en
sait peu encore finalement et le débat
permettra sans doute de dévoiler les
choses donc ceci on le sait quand y'a le
ni droite ni gauche aussi ça en 2002
c'est un des arguments qui avaient le
permis d'expliquer la forte abstention
notamment dans que l'aller les candidats
doivent se dévoiler très vite ils ont
commencé à le faire pour essayer de
lutter contre cette abstention qui est
un vrai risque et ça a été rappelé tout
à l'heure j'en viendrais juste un peu
sur le fait qu emmanuel macron en effet
une structure plus homogène également
sur le plan de la population active et
même sur le plan en termes de classes
sociales
même si il est sur représentée chez les
cadres et que marine le pen les chez les
ouvriers il est mieux représentée sur
l'ensemble des classes sociales que
marine le pen ce qui permet de
comprendre aussi cette homogénéité
territoriale un peu plus élevé que
certains ne le dise merci américaine
mercy qui nouveaux poêles ce la fin de
cette édition
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi à 22h vous
retrouvez sonia mabrouk et son émission
on va plus loin bonne soirée à tous sur
public sénat
[Musique]